remember when tyranny comes it's always
coming under the disguise of their doing
it to protect you but they're not it's
always they're doing it with a better
good they're doing it to stimulate the
economy they're doing it to save the
environment well they printed billions
and trillions of dollars over the last
two years to stimulate the economy to
make it better for everyone but what
happened well they caused astronomical
levels of inflation pushing people the
other into poverty and this is what's
going to come through a central bank
digital currency they're gonna say it's
safer it's secure it's better for the
environment no it's not because it's not
safe and secure if you hold the
incorrect opinion or if you're spreading
supposed misinformation or if you're not
a good citizen it's not going to be safe
and secure at all and also of course
we're in this supposed climate crisis
they're going to program the money so
that you can't spend your money on
whether it's plane tickets meat whatever
it is but of course you'll be allowed to
spend your money on bugs but all of this
is going to be done because you know
we're in this climate crisis and they're
doing it to protect you